Hogwarts Legacy is finally here after
years of rumors hype and excitement I
spent the past several days exploring
the castle flying high above the grounds
creeping through the Forbidden Forest
and slowly peeling back the layers of a
deep storyline which I won't spoil here
today for many fans this is a game 20
years in the making from the moment
Harry first received his letter inviting
him to a world he didn't even know
existed we were all able to imagine what
it would be like to get our own
acceptance letter to Hogwarts and while
the early games had a certain charm they
were limited by technology of the late
90s and early 2000s plus they often
faced Rush development Cycles to
coincide with each new film release
Hogwarts Legacy though is the
culmination of more than five years of
work primarily from Avalanche software a
studio that wanted to aim Higher by
taking on a passion project far beyond
the realm and scope of any game they'd
worked on before could a developer whose
last game was Cars 3 all the way in 2017
actually deliver on the lofty
expectations of such a rabid fan base a
truly Global fan base that spans across
lines of age culture not to mention
hardcore video game players plus
non-gamers who are interested solely
because it takes place in The Wizarding
World well I've now put about 20 hours
into the PS5 deluxe version thanks to an
early copy provided by WB and here's
what I'll say now based on the time I've
had with the game so far Hogwarts Legacy
is the best Wizarding World game ever
made and it's really not particularly
close it's truly a love letter to fans
of the iconic World of Harry Potter
everything from the menus to the sound
effects and music the shops and signage
the classes and teachers they've all
been done with such great respect to the
original lore but not only is Hogwarts
Legacy the best Wizarding World game
ever made it's also a pretty darn good
RPG in its own right surprise though
it's not perfect no game is of course
there are issues here that I expect May
hold it back among some of the more
hardcore Gamers out there and we'll talk
about those here today as well but if I
can be real with you all for just a
moment here flaws and all I am loving
this game so far I haven't been bored a
single moment playing it when it comes
to video games it really all comes back
to that simple word fun is it fun I
don't know yet if it's Game of the Year
material I don't know if it's better
than this better than that all I know is
that my 20 hours with Hogwarts Legacy
has been an absolute blast and I can't
wait to play more so we're gonna get
into the gameplay mechanics I'm Gonna
Leave the story mostly for you to
experience on your own I'll also add
that most of the footage you see today
is from the first few hours of the game
only I will say this one bit about the
story though it's engaging right from
the start and there's enough there that
I want to keep learning more to unravel
the mystery of this ancient magic and
our main character's connection to it it
really does feel like you're starting
out a brand new adventure in The
Wizarding World we all know and love now
one of my early fears of this game is
that without the iconic professors of
the original series and of course the
golden Trio and all their friends The
Experience would somehow feel hollow and
we just exist in the world but wouldn't
have anyone to really care about I'm
happy to say that is not the case and
there are already a few characters I'm
growing attached to through my
playthrough one piece of advice I'll
give those of you who are about to play
the game for the first time it's this
savor it Savor and take your time with
the experience I actually think the game
wants you to take take your time you
won't have access to broom flight right
away you'll come across quite a few
locked rooms in the castle and chances
are you'll even have a puzzle or two you
can't solve because you don't know the
spell you need and while I know many
want to immediately start exploring the
castle even the grounds of hogsmeade
right away I will say that if you don't
do that the game still does a pretty
good job of encouraging this organically
as you simply progress through the early
story missions in fact some of my early
exploring and travels had to actually be
repeated because areas that I went to
check out on my own and get a glimpse of
the game actually ended up taking me
there anyway on a mission now as for the
gameplay how does it actually play and
feel well as I said in my early Hands-On
of the game a few weeks ago the
character controls well combat is super
fun that remains true in this build as
well I've stuck with the normal
difficulty but I've actually been kind
of on the fence about bumping it up to
hard you can change the difficulty at
any time so for the experienced Gamers
out there who'd like a challenge I
recommend going ahead and bumping it up
to hard trying that out and then you can
always bump it back down if you need to
now leading up to this the vertical
slices of gameplay that we had seen
before launched look entertaining I
certainly enjoyed the mission that we
got to play early but now having the
full game in my hands I've been very
pleasantly surprised at the sheer
variety of missions and activities there
are to do in this game we talked in the
beginning about just how many types of
fans they're having to try and please
with this game and again it's hard to
delve too much into where you'll be
going and what you'll be doing with the
fear of me spoiling too much but rest
assured the main story missions offer a
nice variety to keep things fresh
there's also a good balance of puzzles
action exploration and then of course
there's a room of requirement and
nurturing magical beasts which they've
already talked about guys I only
recently unlocked the rumor requirements
still no caring for Magical beasts I
know there were some worried they would
lean too heavily in One Direction and
while it is true you're gonna have to do
a little bit of everything to reach the
end so far they've done a really nice
job at balancing things here for people
of different play styles to where I
think everyone can enjoy this game oh
and there's something that happens in
the story I don't know roughly 10 hours
or so that really changes things up
gameplay-wise in a way that Avalanche
has kept almost entirely Under Wraps
throughout the whole marketing process
trust me guys some of these things we
haven't seen anything about there
haven't even been rumors or men mention
of some of the things you're going to
see here as far as the side quests go
yes your basic Fetch and collect quests
they do make an appearance here but
again there really is a lot of variety
here in terms of the things you can do
so just for a small preview there are
going to be 95 Merlin puzzles of which
I've solved like 10 of these so far
there's 20 ancient magic hot spots 18
Infamous bows I haven't experienced a
single one of those yet despite being 20
hours into the game actually I take that
back you know what I just did my first
ancient magic hot spot so there we go
one of them so far of course that's
going to vary based on your play style
how much exploring you do off the beaten
path especially in the beginning I know
people are going to be exploring a lot
so guys it takes a lot for me to get
emotional when it comes to movies books
video games it's not me trying to be
macho or something I just don't do it
off it just doesn't happen it takes a
lot like I said and yet there was
something about an early moment in this
game for me it was actually when I got
to the common room for the first time
the way the music swells and then
suddenly I was in control of my
character able to freely pan around the
room and walk over to the furniture and
take in all the posters and various
trinkets of the the other students it
was a single room but in that single
room I could see years of hard work from
artists developers coders writers who so
carefully crafted this game now I'm sure
I'm going to discover more things in the
coming days that I love maybe even more
issues or critiques but make no mistake
Hogwarts Legacy is a game for the fans
and a game made by the fans and so when
it comes to that the characters in and
around Hogwarts this starts to touch on
one of the not so good things I've seen
so far in the game and that is the NPCs
and I don't mean the NPCs like Hogwarts
teachers are the ones who give you
missions or even many of the name
students you'll meet up with along the
way no I'm talking about the NPCs that
are just sort of there to exist with the
goal of making the world feel more lived
in and some of the time to be fair this
works really well I particularly enjoyed
how some of the students will linger
about after classes and you can go and
approach and almost always they'll have
a couple of lines of dialogue for you to
interact with each one of them but as
for a lot of the so-called random NPCs I
guess for lack of a better way of
describing them there's a lot to be
desired now I'm not saying I was
expecting like full-on conversations
with every person you meet but there are
a lot of times you'll find NPCs just
stationary staring off into the distance
and they won't really interact with you
or anything you try to do even if they
had just like a single line or two of
dialogue that happens if you maybe
linger for too long I think that would
go a long way toward making it feel a
little bit less awkward and if you're
just kind of running through and only
interacting with the things that you
clearly see you can interact with it's
not a big deal but sometimes you'll pass
by a group of students and they're
having a nice conversation and then
other times you'll pass by and there's
just someone doing this now even though
this is probably my biggest issue so far
it really hasn't detracted from the
overall game for me at least not yet
it's still definitely there and
something I'll notice occasionally as
I'm exploring the castle or even in a
place like hogsmeade as far as the
castle itself guys I mean it's
incredible it's incredible I don't know
what more I can say we kind of felt this
was going to be the case from everything
they'd showed so far and they wanted to
do the castle right and I think they've
done just a phenomenal job with it again
I'm still not finished exploring
everything I haven't collected
everything I haven't found everything
now one thing I would encourage you to
do early on when it comes to exploring I
would turn off the mini map you can and
customize it Hogwarts Legacy includes a
wealth of options for customizing the
HUD such as turning off the damage
numbers and of course the minimap now
most of the options are available in
this menu here but you should also look
through the accessibility menu options
as well because there may be a setting
there you'd like to tweet too so why
turn off the minimap personally I just
found it way more immersive you don't
have all those little icons popping up
you can actually turn off a lot of those
as well on the main screen but what I
found that I like to do is I'll pull up
the big map or Quest log and then Mark
my next Quest and then by pressing up on
the d-pad this is going to give you a
little Golden Trail that kind of exists
like in the world and you can follow
this instead of having to kind of look
down at your map go back and forth and
follow those weird yellow dots to all
the little points of interest one thing
I would love to see them add is sort of
a dynamic HUD option for many of these
elements specifically for your health
and spells essentially a dynamic option
would let you freely explore the world
with no HUD whatsoever as soon as you
pull out your wand to start fighting the
spells in health would Auto appear and
then Auto Hide once again when the
battle is finished now as far as
performance goes all the footage you've
seen so far is running again on a PS5
and performance mode and you're going to
have three modes to choose from Fidelity
Fidelity with Ray tracing and of course
performance mode you can also choose to
cap or uncap the frame rate now if you
have a high refresh rate display that
supports vrr you'll also have the added
options of a balanced mode as well as a
high refresh rate mode now the build I
was playing on did not include the day
one patch which I've been told will add
the Fidelity Ray tracing mode so that's
why you won't see it shown here
hopefully we get a full breakdown on
this game from a site like digital
Foundry because I'm really curious to
see how all these modes perform in terms
of the actual numbers and not just me
looking at it from an actual visual
standpoint as I've done here for me
personally I found the performance mode
with an uncapped frame rate to be my
preference my TV sports vrr I've had
that turned on but I have to say I've
also been tempted a little bit by that
balance mode for that slight increase in
visual Fidelity my guess is that this is
probably like Ratchet and Clank did
where there's like this 40 FPS mode but
with vrr it looks a lot better than 30.
now I did try bumping it up to a high
refresh rate a little bit and I just
found that the details suffer too much
with that one so I went ahead and took
it back down performance and then uncap
the frame rate and I've been happy with
that so far all right the big one I know
a lot of people want to know about
glitches and bugs now to be truthful I
have noticed a number of them during my
20 hours for the game it's an open world
game they're bound to be there you're
going to find them most of mine have
been visual such as robes or like hair
clipping through areas that they
shouldn't inconsistent or flickering
lighting and then probably I guess the
most severe bug I've encountered has
been this weird sort of camera shake
that I think is triggered by something
that's happening near a specific Merlin
puzzle that I was trying to solve so
I've actually returned to this puzzle a
few times because I haven't been able to
solve it yet I think I need a different
spell and I think it's happened to me
twice now definitely more than one
occasion where the camera just kind of
starts shaking fortunately none of it
has been game breaking and with the
camera Shake I was able to correct that
by just kind of leaving the area and
then coming back and it was back to
normal the visuals in this game are
really interesting I have seen some
people on the previous footage I've
shared that say it looks absolutely
stunning some people say that it looks
dated and I can honestly see where both
sides are coming from there are times
especially outside when you're flying
around when you're looking at all the C
scenery I mean this game looks downright
stunning in the common rooms in the
castle the furniture all the details
here I mean the artists should really be
commended for an absolutely outstanding
job they've done to bring the Wizarding
World to life the castle architecture
common room spell effects and many of
the outdoor environments just look truly
spectacular but then at other times
there are things that look dated or you
expect to see a certain effect such as
water dripping from a wet cloak and you
don't again keep in mind I've been
playing on the performance mode so there
are some sacrifices to the visual
Fidelity there and then one of the most
consistent criticisms of the game's
visuals has been the motion capture for
the facial animations unfortunately that
is still present but it's really
inconsistent there are times when I
think it looks solid it's like okay that
looks good that's how it's supposed to
look I believe the ability you possess
obliges you to be well trained and then
other times it just looks a little bit
off still Samantha Dale I've been eager
to meet you you're the student
everyone's been whispering about now as
a fan who's followed pretty much every
news drop about this game I can't help
but wonder how much of this is a result
of the unique development environment
Avalanche had to work in when it was
time to do a lot of this motion capture
they participated in an Autodesk
presentation where they discussed the
challenges of remote work and how many
of their plans just had to completely
change due to not being able to record
and capture many of these actors in
person they had to come up with all
sorts of creative workarounds to get it
to work the door loading issue that I
mentioned in my preview is still present
but I don't think it's fair to call that
a bug it's more just the game having to
load the next area on the bright side it
does not happen often and when it does I
found the loading to be pretty Snappy
and then one that frankly I'm not sure
if it's a bug or not it relates to the
game's music there are times when I'm
exploring the castle both night and day
with music playing music itself
fantastic by the way but then there are
other times when it's totally silent no
music playing whatsoever honestly I'm
not sure if this is intended or not
sometimes it feels almost a little too
quiet when I'm exploring but then
another part of me is like well that
kind of gives you an opportunity to hear
all the sound effects the little sounds
like footsteps and the spell effects in
the game and then remember that lock
picking minigame that I think pretty
much everyone was critical of in the
first preview now I don't know if they
tweak something but for this build that
we played or if it's just me playing the
game more and getting better now but I
have to say it felt much better I'm
knocking these out no problem whatsoever
10 15 seconds tops with every single one
of them so it could very well be that we
judge that one a little bit too harshly
in our first impressions or maybe they
did tweak something under the hood and
make it a little bit more user friendly
now so when it comes to those who are
interested in buying Hogwarts Legacy I
see three different categories first we
have those who love games and The
Wizarding World then we have those who
just primarily Love The Wizarding World
and then we have those who mainly Love
video games and just may be interested
because of something they've seen in a
trailer about this game so for that
ladder group there it really all comes
down to how you feel about the issues
I've mentioned now I fully admit guys
being such a long time fan of this
series it's hard for me to look at the
game from that objective point of view I
simply cannot separate it from the world
that's meant so much to me for so long
and for those people like me that are
fans of The Wizarding World Hogwarts
Legacy is an absolute must play it's a
beautiful example of what happens when
you take a chance on an experience
experienced and passionate development
studio with true fans of the source
material who maybe just haven't had that
chance yet to try something new
something bold while they may not be a
rock star or from software at least not
yet they put their stamp on the industry
in a way that fans of The Wizarding
World Won't soon forget in fact I would
say with Hogwarts Legacy WB and
Avalanche have set off a new phase of
Wizarding World fandom they have laid
the foundation for future Wizarding
World video games and one that can be
built upon for years to come enjoy your
journey in first playthrough of Hogwarts
Legacy and as always thank you all so
much for watching I'll talk to you again
soon